Hey look look guys my name is Jenna
welcome to episode 51 of game
programming so I'm actually really tired
right now but what we're gonna do today
is continue with the game obviously no
let me say that but um what we're gonna
start today is a series of videos going
to deal with the map now many of you
guys really want me to well the map
basically needs to get developed in this
game somehow and and I thought that I
would take the next few episodes to
actually do that
so um Andy will actually send me an
updated sprite a King Jonas right thing
I'll put that in a later episode though
because um cuz yeah but alright now
we're gonna just open up paint.net and
get out image in there so this is
obviously a sprite sheet so what I want
to do here is um basically make our
donor look let's just make a few more
tiles right so first of all let's just
make this entire area green and we'll
probably just do it to this side as well
so this is uh this is the episode where
I teach you guys how to use paint.net
now but seriously uh yeah we're gonna
probably draw out and I'll probably draw
like a flower or something here I like
flowers a lot you can tell and I can't
really tell if that that looks like it's
one whoops it was the wrong tool yeah I
can tell but um I'm sorry and we could
just do this oops
all right so it's gonna be quite the
what there we go
so flower looks good doesn't it might
need a bit not that's fine and we'll
obviously add some some more intricate
details here it'd be a bit of a bit of a
shower that's not talked enough and I
might also um since we are dealing at a
higher resolution here without the Cohen
whoops we're not going like 8 by 8 gone
16 by 16 I might also um yeah I feel
like this knit really needs to be bigger
okay I'll just scale it up so
so say to your big I could work yeah
like a what I got there we go so let's
sort of deal with this first of all
let's get rid of that second of all I
think if I get rid of that as well um
love a better looking flower and maybe
not maybe if I do something like that
might look better I don't know what do I
know about drawing flowers that sir
probably shouldn't
yeah I think I like the original design
better um welcome to the series where
Chennai tries to draw flowers and fails
ah that's gonna be fine
we're just gonna go really simple
graphics just a lot there you go flower
yeah one thing I will do though is this
um this yellow just it's not really
doing well in the saturation department
looks really sad so um I want to fix
that by uh and you never better
hey guy maybe just touch darker
but it's still more saturated all right
that's gonna be our flower and enough
would be rock let's just draw something
really simple for the rock so maybe like
something like that could probably work
and then again we'll take some lighter
shades for the top because that's how we
roll and some dark shades for the bottom
and voila we got our rock yeah
if any of you guys want to send me your
sprites go ahead I'll probably use them
because I doubt I'll be worse than this
that flower is way too big so let's
scale that down a bit
hey there we go all right whoops that's
shouldnít happens okay paint pocket
that's F all right cool
so that's what our thing looks like
right now let's go actually I don't like
I don't like this um it's too thin let's
make it a bit yeah there we go cool
so let's take a look at actually I'm
popping that in the code if we go back
to our sprite stuff we can add a few
more files so over here in brass let's
duplicate that twice we'll call one
flower we'll call one Rock
they're both 16 size sprites we know
that if we look back in here actually I
think I'm still got paint on that open
we can see that that's zero right that's
a zero zero that's obviously gonna be
one zero and maybe two zero so the X of
that is one of the flower and the rock
is too awesome so let's go back into our
random level class quickly that's the
thing that's doing it and we can say the
way we're actually drawing a number from
zero to three basically anywhere from
zero to three so if we go back into our
level class are we here in our get tile
method we say that if that tile plus if
if um if that tiles array at a
particular index is equal to zero we're
returning to La Crosse so let's change
this around a bit let's look at that
twice and say that if it if it equals
one will return flower cauliflower and
finally if it equals two will return
tile dots what's it on Rock all right so
obviously these haven't been read yet so
we can pop over to the tile class really
quickly and duplicate this grass twice
and from here we'll just call one flower
and we'll call one Rock
and we alum will also you know adjust
this so that's flour it's gonna be rock
so yeah I'm gonna create self classes
for each of them if we create class
flour tile we'll make sure that it is in
the tile package hit finish and if we go
back to well first of all let's add the
constructor so kind of all that's really
all we need to do right we do also need
to grab if we go through our grass tile
class we alternated rather than run the
method from that copy and paste that
into our um where are we flower tile
here we go well the best I bet so there
you go it's gonna look exactly the same
as cross tile really but for the rock
tile it's gonna be a bit different so if
we crack last Rock tile finish let's pop
the constructor and let's pop the thing
in the same thing that we that we put
into um flower tile and one with y
addition right if we go back to tile you
see that we've got this solid method
let's copy our solid method and put it
into rock tile just below the render so
I'm actually a matter where it is but
yeah and it was it saying it changes
return false into return true so we know
it's solid and in the future when we
actually implement a collision detection
which will actually be pretty soon
probably a few episodes it'll probably
be within the next five episodes we can
actually um when actually you know not
go through rocks so let's launch our
game see what we get and look at that we
get a bunch of interesting things so
first of all we can see that there's a
lot more grass tiles there aren't any of
the two tiles that we've picked now the
first thing that comes to mind is that
we simply haven't set the sprite to be
the freshest fried so we go to tile you
can see that all these sprites that are
actually equal to sprite or grass so
let's change the flower - sprite our
flower which we created earlier and drop
just right out rock let's watch a cab
and look at that we have different
different tiles now so yeah those are my
really horrible tiles if you guys want
to send me tiles you just um feel free
to maybe I need one
send me some tiles I think he did
actually I think you did I'm not sure
anyway trees would be nice as well so
that's a quick quick little thing you
guys want to help me out but other than
that that is episode if you want to
gamer drumming and I'll see you guys in
the next episode love you guys
you